foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will be discussing when we
should see the second season of House of
the Dragon the release date for the
follow-up of House of the dragon's
incredibly successful first season is on
the mind of every fan ever since they
aired the final episode on Sunday after
the season one finale of House of the
Dragon I saw there were hundreds or even
thousands of fans saying it might be
several years before we see the next
season of the show well according to a
recent interview with also the dragon
showrunner we might not have to wait as
long as everyone thinks as you all know
we are already only a few months away
from the new year and House of the
Dragon should start filming shortly
thereafter now during that same
interview Ryan Condell did say House of
the Dragon might be able to air before
the new year is over as difficult as it
may seem to film a whole season and
release it in that same year House of
the Dragon showrunner said it could be
done after all Game of Thrones has done
this before another thing some of you
might might be wondering is what will
happen in House of the dragon's second
season well as you all can imagine there
will obviously be a lot of death and
destruction it's almost unavoidable when
you have over a dozen fire-breathing
dragons flying around in the sky as of
right now it seems as though Rainier's
initial strategy is to blockade King's
Landing from the sea with the valerion
fleet while holding an aerial advantage
in the skies now that is easier said
than done when the other side has
dragons as well elsewhere she will need
to make sure she has the backing of
houses Aaron manderly and Stark the
latter of which Game of Thrones fans
will best know as the family of eddard
bran Arya and many other fan favorites
from Winterfell and that's only to name
a few we've already been to house
Baratheon of Storm's end where Lou
carries valerion was unfortunately
killed in the season 1 finale however
will this mean that the show's action
will expand out from the capital of
Westeros as well as Dragonstone and
birthmark thankfully House of the Dragon
showrunner has already given us a
confirmation about this very thing in
the same interview he said the show will
definitely expand its scope in the
second season since the dance of the
Dragons has officially begun that means
the blacks and the greens will have to
find allegiances from different kingdoms
and armies all over Westeros he also
said he doesn't think House of the
Dragon will be as vast as the original
Game of Thrones however he did suggest
that we might see new locations that
were never seen in the main series which
is very exciting if you ask me we should
also see a lot new faces in the second
season now that we will be heading back
to locations like the Vale in Winterfell
HBO will need to find actors to fill the
shoes in those major houses House of the
Dragon showrunner Ryan condo also
confirmed we will see Lord Stark during
the second season this has me very
excited as well because Hal Stark and
their home of wonderfell was always one
of my favorite aspects of the main show
it will be very fun to see a dragon
flying over their ancestral seat once
again another thing we will see in The
Following season is a lot more dragons
as I'm sure most of you already know
George R Martin confirmed we would see
17 dragons during the Run of House of
the Dragon you know I've always thought
this this was a cool story it's when I
like uh so I'm I'm looking forward to
seeing it come alive on screen and of
course I'm looking forward to the
dragons uh you know obviously I love I
love the dragons and we had three of
them in uh in Game of Thrones but now we
got like 17 of them and uh hopefully
they'll they'll each have their own
personalities they'll be instantly
recognizable uh when you when you see
them the colors and and all of that
because the dragons do have uh do have
personalities uh in the books and it'll
be great to see that come alive and the
dragon writers
um that's that's all uh that's all
pretty cool
so far we've only seen about nine of
them in the first season therefore we do
still have a lot more dragons who need
to make their grand entrance obviously
one of the main things I'm looking
forward to is seeing the full reaction
from everyone when they find out what
happened to lucari's valerion all we saw
was the look on rhaenyra's face when
Damon gave her the news but now I want
to see exactly how she will strike back
I also want to see if Allison and Serato
react the same way they did in Fire and
Blood it will be very interesting to see
how HBO and their writers handle
everything moving forward they've
definitely already made a number of the
characters a lot more sympathetic than
how George R Martin had them written I'm
interested to see how this will affect
them and their actions in the future as
of right now we do not have an official
release date from HBO and I do not think
we will be getting one anytime soon if
you remember we did not get an official
release date for House of the Dragon
until shortly before the first season
aired we will most likely have to wait
for them to to finish the filming of
every scene before we know for sure one
thing we do know is HBO will begin
filming the second season at the
beginning of the new year so it will not
be long before we start getting a lot
new updates about the show like I have
said before I will be here releasing
videos every step of the way during the
making of the new season as soon as
filming does begin and the set photos
start hitting the internet we will know
exactly what's happening in a lot of the
scenes in the second season as always I
will make update videos about when
they're filming where they're filming
and who is there working on set so as
long as you're here watching all of my
new videos you'll never be left in the
dark as of right now it might seem like
it will be forever before we start
seeing The Following season but the days
will fly by a lot faster than you think
I still remember when HBO announced that
the making of Game of Thrones season 8
would last for over a year and a half
everyone thought they would actually die
before the final season of Game of
Thrones would release but that's now
over four year years ago not only did
HBO release another new show but we've
already seen its first season it seemed
Like Only Yesterday House of the Dragon
was airing its first episode but now
we're already discussing the filming of
the second season believe me the new
season will be here before we know it
then we'll be right back here wondering
when they will make season three let's
just hope that during the off season we
will get some more major announcements
from either HBO or George RR Martin
himself it would be very nice if they
said the Jon Snow series was moving
ahead or if we finally get an official
release date for The Winds of Winter as
always I will make sure you're up to
date on any new information or
developments regarding House of the
Dragon Game of Thrones and its successor
shows as well as the wins of winter or A
Song of Ice and Fire make sure you
subscribe and stick around for a while
because there's a lot more videos
heading your way I want to thank all of
you for watching this one and I hope
I'll see you back here for my next one
have a great day everyone I will see you
again very soon own bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign